if you work with people that aren't as
good as you then you know you become a
country of midgets Who am I to be the
best Who am I to deserve working with
the best people say that you know I
built Facebook or Steve Jobs build a
Polly not true rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
copy and sip on today's message work
with the best over to you Steve Jobs
also if you want to know it's Steve Jobs
and others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 2:54
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence to link to join is in the
description below I say well I think you
should go get a job as a busboy or
something till you find something you're
really passionate about
[Music]
I've noticed something in my life which
is people that are really good want to
work with the best people they can find
hopefully people that are even better
than them you know I mean that's my view
of things as if if you work with people
that aren't as good as you then you know
you become a country of midgets if you
work with people that are better than
you then you really grow what Steve Jobs
is saying makes sense work with the best
and you will win I think the hard part
though for people is believing that
they're worthy of being the best and
working with the best I think a lot of
people go through I've seen Who am I
like Who am I to have this big ambition
Who am I gonna have this big dream Who
am I to be the best Who am I to deserve
working with the best and they feel like
an imposter now if I'm being totally
honest I don't have all the answers
myself I still need to learn to believe
in myself more why should Kanye make a
believe woody or believe shoe line why
should Howard Schultz join my Board of
Advisors and board of directors I don't
believe that I'm on that level yet I
don't believe that I deserve to work
with the best yet I'm still on my path
and
so I don't have all the answers but I
have grown a lot over the past X number
of years and there's one secret that has
really helped me and that is change
comes with consistency no matter where
you came from no matter what
circumstances you grew up in you can
escape those circumstances you can
become a new better more confident
person if you are consistently dedicated
to changing yourself the example that
really showed this to me was when I
signed a 3-year deal with the CEO of
sage was this giant corporation twelve
thirteen thousand employees
multi-billion dollars in revenue and I
was doing a live Q&A show with him where
every month we would sit down and we'd
take questions from you guys believe
nation and I was driving with my dad and
I just signed his three-year deal I'll
die with my dad and he asked me what
gives you the confidence to think that
you're on the same level as his big-time
CEO and he was asking a genuine
admiration genuine like wow look what
you did as opposed like who are you to
think you can do this and I thought
about it and I didn't think at the time
that it was a huge deal because Who am I
hanging around with I'm watching videos
of Steve Jobs and watching videos of
Oprah Winfrey I'm hanging around with
these people on a consistent basis and I
don't notice that on the day-to-day but
week to week month to month even year to
year I feel a little bit more confident
I referred to believe in myself a little
bit more through that consistency by
everyday surrounding myself with people
who are doing much greater things they
slowly pull me up towards them now it's
taking me years to get here if you go
back on my channel you see who I was
before I had the same opinions I had the
same thoughts but the confidence has
grown the presence has grown the self
belief has grown and I still have a long
way to go to get to ultimately where I
want to be but my message is if you guys
want to change where you're at if you're
unhappy with your level of confidence if
you're unhappy with your circumstances
it doesn't have to remain that forever
whether my channel is the thing that
helps you or you design your own program
if you constantly inject positivity
belief courageousness into your regular
daily habits and environment you will
grow you will get stronger you will
build that muscle and you will end up
feeling worthy of working with the best
I think we all know that we want to work
with the best but the first challenge is
believe in
were worthy of being the best and
working with them too now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know do
you struggle with the belief that you
are worthy of working with the absolute
best in the world I'd love to hear from
you please share your story in the
comments below
there's a little bit of this cultural
bias towards thinking that you know one
person does this alright I mean people
say that you know I built Facebook or
Steve Jobs built Apple or whatever but
you know that's really not true right I
mean it's we're we're people we we
helped but there were thousands and
thousands of other people involved in
building these things and the reality is
is that as strong as any one individual
is no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are gonna get thrown at
them in anything that you do and one of
the ways that I think we maintain
resilience is by having co-founders and
partners who complement our strengths
and fortify our weaknesses and can kind
of encourage us and give us a push to to
keep going when things are tough and
there's actually a lot of data on this
that suggests that companies that get
started with more co-founders are more
likely to be successful and it isn't
quite clear exactly from that data why
that's the case although it is very
clear in terms of the outcome for the
startup is that it is the case but I
would guess that the reason why that's
the case is because of this resilience
point where people who start something
by themselves
I just think like there's no way that
any one person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
build a startup or take on any kind of
other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
I don't know I mean maybe over time one
of them doesn't like it and drops out
but you still have enough strength from
the team to power through all the
challenges that you have and that's kind
of how you go and new at Facebook today
one of the things that I always find a
little bit funny is again that so much
attention is placed on on me is the
person running the company whereas I
think you know people like Cheryl who
really you know as my partner running
the whole business or you know folks
like Chris Cox who run a huge amount of
our product or Mike Schroepfer who's our
chief technology officer and kind of
make sure that a ton of what we're doing
works RJ Parikh who runs all of our
global infrastructure and in all the
data centers around the world we
couldn't make Facebook work without
those people right and and there were
really hard days where where I'm
sure what to do next and and they keep
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would become like a little beacon
if you want more Steve Jobs check out
the top ten rules video that I made on
him it's all but it's amazing the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you tend to get told that
the world is the way it is just to live
your life inside the world try not to
bash into the walls too much